we couldn't be happier for you outside
you really found yourself in frozen too
now we're not saying that show yourself
is the new let it go but there's
something about this song that hit us
right in the fields we loved how you
transform during this musical number you
knew that a cartoon could be so
beautiful you're finally where you're
meant to be doing what you were born to
do your parents would be so proud you'll
be fine frozen to was everything we'd
hoped for and more every song was
amazing but show yourself truly pulls at
our heartstrings we're about to put it's
lyrics under the microscope keep
watching to find out the hidden meaning
behind show yourself frozen fans weren't
convinced that Disney could match the
soundtrack of the original film but some
might even say that they surpassed it
let it go is still one of the greatest
hits the franchise has to offer but show
yourself is nothing short of amazing
from its chilling vocals to its
underlying meaning to every verse in
between show yourself is sung by
Broadway legend idina menzel
an actress Evan Rachel Wood who portray
L sang Pina Doudna respectively together
these amazing women make for one of the
most emotional songs in Disney history
show yourself is all about else's
journey to self-discovery its lyrics
give insight on just how much Elsa has
suffered since accidentally freezing on
his head when they were kids
reduce the staff limit her contact with
people
keep her powers hidden from everyone she
was taught to conceal don't feel by her
father who was afraid of how his people
would react to her unique gifts Elsa
transforms into the best version of
herself while singing show yourself
everything from her hair to her gown to
her confidence gets magnified as she
steps foot on Otto Holland for the very
first time will dissect the song one
verse at a time so stay tuned for the
big reveal all right let's jump right in
the first first finding out the truth
about her powers was a super big deal
for Elsa she's so nervous and excited
that she's literally trembling and not
from the cold
Elsa reveals that she feels like she's
coming home to a friend she's always
known she can sense something bigger
than herself at the heart of the Otto
Harland
this first confirms that Elsa's Spirit
comes from this magical place so
basically your spirit lived long before
she became Agner and I do knows first
born the pre-chorus in the pre-chorus
also admits to being a fortress where
cold secret suicide she bonds with the
person she searches for because she
knows that they have similar secrets in
the first frozen film Elsa creates an
ice castle at the top at the North
Mountain where she finally feels at home
could she have been trying to recreate a
tall fallen
despite its existence being buried in
her deep subconscious beautiful thank
you you a beautiful earth I mean fuller
you don't
Buller but more beautiful thank you the
core is the chorus of show yourself has
got to be the most emotional bit of the
songs Elsa is ready to meet her maker
and she wants answers she admits that
she's been searching for someone all her
life and that she's ready to learn the
truth the second verse
Elsa gets more excited the closer she
gets to the river full of memory in the
second verse she sings about being
certain that she's moments from the
truth she admits to being different and
feeling torn up about it
you're older in the cell knowing do you
ever worry about the notion better
nothing's permanent the second chorus at
the beginning of the song Elsa is
trembling but by the second chorus her
tremors have stopped her transformation
has already begun and she's coming into
her own she knows that she's seconds
away from finding the truth and that she
feels safe and welcomed the third verse
[Music]
it's here that we find out that the
voice that has been calling out to Elsa
belongs to her mother Queen I do not
theirs just voice voice what does that
mean her mom is welcoming her home the
third chorus but things get really
interesting in the third chorus which is
sung by both Elsa and I do not
Elsa steps into her power and throws
herself into something new and soon I do
nose voice fades away when she reveals
that Elsa is the one that she's been
waiting for all of her life at this
point in the song Elsa goes too far in
the river full of memory she finds out
the truth about her grandfather and
freezes solid but this phenomenon was
foreshadowed in the first chorus in
which Elsa sings I'm dying to meet you
so basically Elsa knew that she had to
pass a way to find out the truth she had
to freeze solid to become the person she
was looking for and that person was the
fifth spirit hey you are you subscribed
to the things yet hit that big red
subscribe button if you haven't already
we post new and exciting content every
single day so click that Bell to be
notified wherever we upload a new frozen
to video go on YouTube settings and turn
on notifications if you're watching on
your mobile this way you'll never miss a
beat
that's a wrap on the show yourself lyric
breakdown which frozen to track is your
favorite let us know in the comments
thanks for watching the things give this
video a big thumbs up if you like warm
hugs we'll catch you next time
[Music]